[Applause]
[Music]
in 1980 the historical medellin cartel
leader pablo escobar
had an idea basically he had a vision
something of a dream and that was to
turn colombia into a narco state a
country where the government
and all public institutions would be
directly controlled by drug trafficking
such was his commitment that in 1982
as i think you'll probably know pablo
escobar himself one of the most
important mobsters in all of history
gained a seat at the colombian chamber
of representatives
and it's important to bear in mind that
it's one thing for the mafia to buy or
bribe a politician and quite another for
them to
hold all the power directly can you
imagine a country where the police the
army
all administrative officials and even
the courts themselves were ultimately
under the direct
orders of drug dealers of course if
pablo escobar's vision had panned
out colombia wouldn't only have much
higher levels of drug production and
export but the medellin cartel itself
would
become untouchable invincible he would
have gained complete
impunity to do and undo whatever he
wanted
at will fortunately pablo escobar never
managed to carry out his dream
however today three decades later it
looks like his dream
is now being realized but this time
we're not talking about colombia we're
talking
about venezuela
apparently the four characters you're
looking at right now don't only control
the country they are also the leaders of
an international
crime and drug trafficking network of
course we're talking about nicolas
maduro the president of venezuela
diosdado
the powerful president of the national
constituent assembly who may already
rank as the strongest man in the regime
and tarik al-assami former vice
president and current minister of
industry in national production whose
personal fortune
according to dea calculations surpasses
the three
billion dollar mark and the fourth is
nestor rivera minister of internal
affairs justice and peace who to top it
off was the previous national account
narcotics office director well
everything indicates that these
four people are leading the
transformation of venezuela into a narco
state listen up
[Music]
the mafia takes control
venezuela is in shreds hunger is
increasing inflation is out of control
and hundreds of thousands of people are
fleeing the country even hospitals don't
have basic supplies like
medicine analytical equipment or
plasters there's such a huge mess that
the pdvsa itself the venezuelan
state-owned oil company with the most
reserves in the world
is bankrupt
[Music]
consider this to this day pdvsa has so
many embargo orders that in order to
sell the increasingly dwindling
venezuelan oil it's beginning to resort
to tricks and techniques used by
hollywood movie style smugglers
for example since venezuelan oil
companies are at risk of being
confiscated to settle all outstanding
debts on the oil they transport pdvsa
has begun
to transfer oil from its ships to other
ships with the cuban flag out at sea
these ships are then responsible for
taking the crude oil to its destination
thus
avoiding being seized because folks in
venezuela practically everything that
has value has been or is being looted
corruption has reached
almost every corner of the country so
the bolivarian revolution promised
prosperity what they forgot to clarify
is that all that prosperity would only
be for a few for the friends of the
revolution of course
don't believe me well take a look at
this
many regime members promote and lead
operations for gas contraband to sell in
brazil and colombia they are also mostly
responsible for food and medicine
contraband which
the state buys and then sells on the
black market they have looted public
accounts and tens of billions of dollars
have disappeared from the government and
from the pdbsa
[Music]
in venezuela even the central bank's u.s
dollars have been looted yep you really
did hear that right
allow me to explain this one of the
first things that the chavez regime did
was
implement a rigid exchange control they
fixed for example the official exchange
between the bolivar
and the us dollar to a rate that had
nothing to do with the numbers on the
street
that way the government's friends could
access u.s dollars with just
a handful of bolivars bolivars that due
to the country's current hyperinflation
are
now worth practically nothing
the maneuver was so well perfected that
it is estimated that 20
of all imports declared in recent years
have been completely false operations
that were done
for the sole purpose of obtaining
dollars at the official exchange rate
and then to save them in foreign
accounts and this is important because
according to estimates we could be
talking
about a theft of more than a hundred
billion dollars
and of course pdvsa hasn't escaped this
plunder
a group of companies lent 7.2 billion
bolivares to pdvsa
which when exchanged at the black market
rate would be about 42 million dollars
but when exchange at the official rate
would become approximately 600 million
dollars
which were deposited in an account in
malta cesar batis
venezuelan journalist but of course
since no more can be squeezed out of the
country the regime giants have sought a
new alternative source of income
[Music]
[Applause]
a narco state
the issue of drug dealers in venezuela
isn't new it has
however evolved allow me to explain for
years colombian cartels tried to use
roots through venezuela to distribute
their products
and of course to do so they began
bribing policemen national guard members
high officials etc these
people would then turn a blind eye this
was the first
stage as it worked dealers got to know
the land better and figured out who they
could trust
and who they couldn't so they moved into
the second stage of things which was
something like alright now that we have
a deal i'll give you some more money but
you don't
only look away you've also got to
protect me and transport my merchandise
and this second stage was implemented
later many colombian mobsters realized
that given the enormous pressure they
had from the colombian government and
the dea they'd be
safer in venezuela so at the beginning
of the 21st century
that's precisely what happened many of
these sinister merchants moved their
operations centers from colombia to
venezuela
and that's when they started to closely
collaborate
with the authorities there and i mean
really closely
so what do you think the venezuelan
government did then well in 2005 they
decided to
expel the dea from venezuelan territory
and suspend their agreement
to monitor narco flights therefore
venezuelan territory became
a kind of refuge for drug traffickers
the united states could no longer keep
track of them there pretty fantastic for
them isn't it
of course in exchange for getting rid of
the united states they had to pay
a modest commission the regime giants
they needed to live off something right
well
that was the third stage but hold on a
moment here because that's how we got to
the fourth and last stage
which is where we're at right now
business
was going well so well in fact that many
of the bolivarian revolutionary leaders
ask themselves a question
we have the government the police the
army and a lot of resources why on earth
should we
share anything with the colombians or
whoever else
is
so do you know what happened then well
the venezuelan authorities began
arresting all of the drug traffickers
who didn't want to cooperate with them
by
giving their roots as well as their
distribution business to them
that's how people such as maximiliano
bonilla aka valenciano the chief of the
envogardo office hector herrmann
puitrago aka martin llanos diego perez
aka diego rest rojo and daniel barrera
barrera
aka el loko fell all of them were found
in the list of most significant
traffickers
so everything indicates that right now
in venezuela even though there are tons
of criminal groups operating in the area
the government giants hold
the ultimate control in control of
characters like diosdado cabello
allegedly the most important
leader of the los salas cartel the
cartel formed by the leaders of the
bolivarian government
the venezuelan people suffer under
corrupt politicians who tightened their
grip over power
while lining their own pockets we are
imposing costs on figures like diosdado
cabello who exploit their official
positions to engage in narcotics
trafficking
money laundering embezzlement of state
funds and other corrupt
activities us treasury secretary stephen
munchen
in fact one of cabello's own personal
assistants lis me salazar fled venezuela
in 2014 with the help of the dea
and his statement couldn't be more
forceful in addition to providing
evidence on the organization's operation
he stated that mr caballo president of
the national
constituent assembly gives direct orders
on the roots and the departure of
boats loaded with prohibited substances
and he's not the only one testimonies
are accumulating in the offices of the
dea
for example there's waleed mclead
statement from when he was arrested in
colombia in 2011.
macleod was one of the most powerful
drug traffickers in venezuela for
example he controlled puerto cabello
which according to the dea was the exit
point for most of the narcotics
distributed from the country
well after his arrest maclead declared
with great detail that he had done
business with several dozens of
venezuelan generals high-level
government officials such as henry
rangel silva who was
later named minister of defense or hugo
carvajal former army intelligence
director who supposedly paid him fifty
thousand dollars a week which is
certainly a nice salary
he also claimed to have financed one of
hugo chavez's campaigns in exchange for
concessions in puerto cabello
with all these relationships it's easy
to understand how in november 2016
afrain antonio campo flores and
francisco flores de freitas two of the
venezuelan first lady's nephews were
convicted in a new york court for
conspiring to traffic
hundreds of kilos of narcotics and folks
according to current estimates the
business in venezuela it won't stop
growing
between 15 and 20 percent of all the
cocaine that moves in the world every
year
passes through this country and not only
that apparently the number of
laboratories is also
rising a great deal of course the
giants of the bolivarian revolution need
money to keep the
structures of repression loyal the army
the police the
national guard also in exchange for
working in venezuela the different
criminal groups based there from the
mafia to the paramilitaries and the
colombian guerrillas
support the regime and since there's
good business maduro and company are
still filling their pockets
unfortunately the consequences of all of
this are terrible
for one looting all public resources has
led the country to ruin and on top of
that it's fueling an enormous amount of
violence
see according to data from the
venezuelan violence observatory in 2017
there were 89 homicides per 100 000
inhabitants in the country that is more
than 26
000 people who lost their lives
violently
[Music]
venezuela has become the most dangerous
country in all of latin america and the
situation in some areas like caracas is
even worse the country's homicide rate
skyrocketed in 2017 to 130 people
per hundred thousand inhabitants
meanwhile members of the government are
taking advantage of the situation and
developing fortunes which they're using
to buy properties all over the world
from the dominican republic
to madrid indeed madrid is a city to
which not only thousands of venezuelans
fleeing the disaster are arriving but
also many of the relatives of the soles
cartel bosses and other high position
members loyal to the revolution going to
i now sometimes find myself sitting in
restaurants in madrid
right next to people whom i wouldn't
feel comfortable ever seeing caracas
leopoldo lopez gill father of leopoldo
lopez
a leading opposition politician who has
been kept under house arrest in caracas
unfortunately the bolivarian regime has
found its best ally in drug dealing both
to fill their pockets and to keep their
power in short de viewer
for now this is just how things are so i
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button and don't forget
to subscribe also don't forget to check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also of
course
this channel is possible because of our
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always thank you for watching
a
[Applause]